♪
♪ ♪
>> Greg: DELICIOUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
HAPPY THURSDAY EVERYBODY, YOU
LOOK FANTASTIC.
THERE I GO TALKING TO MYSELF
AGAIN.
DID YOU EVER NOTICE HOW LEFTY
POLITICIANS NEVER CONCERN
THEMSELVES WITH THREATS UNTIL
THEY ARE THE TARGETS?
I REFER TO NEW YORK CITY
COUNCILWOMAN -- HER DAD WAS AN
ELEVATOR MECHANIC SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHY HERS DOESN'T GO ALL
THE WAY TO THE TOP.
LAST WEEK AND SHE URGED
BUSINESSES NOT TO DIAL 911 WHEN
FACED WITH CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
THAT'S GREAT ADVICE, WHO SHOULD
THEY CALL?
DOMINOES AND HOPE THE DELIVERY
GUY IS PACKING HEAT?
MAYBE YOU CAN SCALD THE MUGGER
WITH HOT CHEESE.
DAYS BEFORE A GHOUL STABBED A
VETERAN EMT WORKER TO DEATH, SHE
RELEASED A PUBLIC SAFETY GUIDE
URGING MERCHANTS TO CALL 311,
NOT 911 TO SEEK MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ENGAGE IN COMMUNITY
MEDIATION RATHER THAN CALL THE
COPS.
THAT WILL WORK.
311, WHAT'S YOUR EMERGENCY?
MY STORE IS BEING BUM-RUSHED BY
100 JUVENILE DELINQUENTS AND
THEY ARE DESTROYING THE PLACE.
COULD YOU GET A PSYCHOLOGIST OUT
THERE TO TALK TO THEM?
THEY ADVISE MERCHANTS TO GIVE
THE PERSON CAUSING HARM THE
CHANCE TO CORRECT THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
SAY NO, STOP, OR THAT IS NOT
OKAY.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SAY THE SAME
THING TO A GUY ROBBING YOU AT
GUNPOINT AS A GIRL SAYS TO A GUY
TRYING TO GET TO SECOND BASE ON
HER FIRST DATE TWO YOU WOULD BE
BETTER OFF OFFERING HIM A
CINNABON AND A HAND JOB.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ODDLY, THEY DO GO TOGETHER.
THE GUIDE ALSO SUGGESTED ASKING
THE ATTACKER IF YOU GUYS WENT TO
HIGH SCHOOL TOGETHER.
PLEASE STOP STABBING FOR A
SECOND SO I CAN GET MY
HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOK I THINK YOU
SAT BEHIND ME IN HISTORY.
YOU THINK SOMEONE THIS NUTS
WOULD KNOW YOU CAN'T REASON WITH
CRAZY PEOPLE.
THAT IS HER SUGGESTION RATHER
THAN CALLING THE COPS.
GUESS WHO CALLED THE COPS
YESTERDAY?
SHE CLAIMS SHE DIDN'T CALL 911,
PROBABLY BECAUSE SHE FORGOT THE
NUMBER.
BUT AFTER RECEIVING THREATENING
PHONE CALLS LIKELY OVER HER BAD
IDEAS, SHE OR HER STAFF
CONTACTED THE AUTHORITIES.
IF THIS IS AN IRONY DEFINED.
I WONDER HOW THAT CALL WENT.
543 THINK, SERGEANT JONES
SPEAKING.
YOU'LL NEVER GUESS GUESS WHO
THIS IS, IT'S COUNCILWOMAN
TIFFANY -- HELLO?
IT APPEARS THE ONLY JUSTICE THAT
SHE IS A PART OF HIS POETIC.
I'M WILLING TO BET SHE DIDN'T
REFERENCE THAT GUIDE WHEN THESE
THREATS CAME THROUGH WHICH IS A
SHAME, HOW WOULD THEY KNOW
THREATENING PEOPLE IS BAD IF SHE
DIDN'T TELL THEM IT'S NOT OKAY?
I BET SHE DIDN'T SEEK OUT A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL OR
EVEN GIVE THE CALLERS A CHANCE
TO CORRECT THEIR BEHAVIOR OR
JUST HANG UP.
AT THAT SHE DIDN'T CALL 311
EITHER BECAUSE THEY WOULD TELL
HER TO CALL THE COPS.
SHE TELLS VICTIMS WHO UNLIKE HER
ARE FACE-TO-FACE WITH ACTUAL
PHYSICAL THREATS NOT TO CALL THE
COPS, BUT THAT IS WHAT SHE OR
HER STAFF DID WITH VOICE MAILS?
WHO DRESSES THIS DUMB BROAD IN
THE MORNING AND PACKS HER
WONDER WOMAN LUNCH BOX?
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE THREATS TO
HER ARE BAD.
AS MY MOTHER OFTEN SAID AN EYE
FOR AN EYE DOESN'T WORK
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A PERSON WHO IS ALREADY
BLIND AS [BLEEP].
MY MOTHER HAD A MOUTH ON HER.
SHE WAS RIGHT!
PEOPLE GETTING MURDERED AND
ROBBED AND SHE IS OFFERING
BROCHURES.
SHE GETS A THREAT AND NOW SHE IS
THE VICTIM?
SO SHE CALLS THE COPS?
SOMETHING SHE DOESN'T WANT FOR
YOU BECAUSE IF YOU CALL THEM
IT'S PROOF THE COPS ARE 100%
NECESSARY IN THIS WORLD THAT
PEOPLE LIKE HER HAD CREATED IN
THE FIRST PLACE -- SHE HAS NO
FROM THE OTHER D FUNDERS LIKE
CORI BUSH WHO WANTS COPS OFF THE
STREETS AS VULNERABLE CITIZENS
PAY THOUSANDS FOR PRIVATE
SECURITY JUST AS DEMOCRATS DENY
HER IDEOLOGY, SHE IS WOKE.
>> DEFUNDING THE POLICE HAS TO
HAPPEN, WE NEED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE AND PUT THAT MONEY IN A
SOCIAL SAFETY NETS BECAUSE WE
ARE TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
>> LETS DEMILITARIZED THE POLICE
COME IT'S NOT USE MONEY FOR
S.W.A.T. GEAR, LET'S NOT USE
MONEY TO BUY -- THE THING ABOUT
DEFUND THE POLICE AS WE TO TELL
THE ENTIRE NARRATIVE, PEOPLE
HERE DEFUND THE POLICE BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY WILL SAY?
TABLE SAY REALLOCATE, DIVEST,
MOVE BUT IT'S THE SAME THING.
>> IF YOU COULD DO IT AGAIN,
WOULD YOU STILL DOUBLE DOWN OR
USE THAT SLOGAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE HE'S
INTERVIEWING HIS REPLACEMENT.
WHY ARE SO MANY WOMEN IN POWER
IGNORING WOMEN IN PERIL?
IT SEEMS MURDER VICTIMS ONLY
MATTER IF THEY USE THE WRONG
PRONOUN BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CRIME STATS, FAR OUTWEIGHING THE
REVERSE AND IT'S GETTING WORSE.
WHERE IS AOC OR HER PROGRESSIVE
ILK?
THEY WILL GLADLY TELL YOU ABOUT
THE THREATS AGAINST THEIR LIVES,
THE ONLINE HIT, THE VOICE MAILS
AND WHO COULD FORGET AOC
NARROWLY ESCAPING DEATH WHEN A
BUNCH OF WHITE PEOPLE WITH AN
AVERAGE AGE OF 55 CAME WITHIN A
HALF-MILE OF HER OFFICE.
ON ONE DAY.
THEY WANT TO SICK THE FEDS FEDS
ON THE PEOPLE WHEN THEIR
FEELINGS ARE HURT BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING OTHER WOMEN
FROM PHYSICAL HARM, THEY DON'T
GIVE A DAMN.
WHEN ONE WOMAN GOT BEAT BY A
PSYCHOPATH, SHE TWEETED "SUBWAY
VIOLENCE IS A ONE IN A MILLION
EVENT.
SHE LITERALLY TURNED A VICTIM
INTO A STATISTIC AND AN
INCORRECT ONE BY FAR, HERE IS A
REAL STAT.
SERIOUS CRIMES ROSE 35.4% OVER
LAST SUMMER'S RECENT HIGHS, THAT
IS INCREDIBLE.
THAT STAT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE
IT'S PROBABLY RACIST.
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN CAN'T
MATTER IF THE PERPETRATOR CANNOT
ALSO CLAIM SOME FORM OF
VICTIMHOOD UNLESS IT HAPPENS TO
HER ON EMAIL, SOCIAL MEDIA OR BY
PHONE.
NOW THERE ARE MORE MINORITY
VICTIMS THANKS TO DEMOCRATS IN
HIS LEFT WING WOMEN WHO CHAMPION
IT LIKE THEIR LIVES DIDN'T
DEPEND ON IT.
THE NEXT TIME YOU'RE ATTACKED BY
A KNIFE WIELDING THUG IT JUST
ASK WHO THEY HAD FOR GYM CLASS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WELCOME!
TONIGHT'S GUESTS, SHE'S SO SHARP
YOU CAN CARVE A PUMPKIN WITH
HER.
MORGAN ORTEGA!
HE IS MORE THAN AN ACTOR WHO
PLAYS TOUGH GUYS AND IF YOU
DISAGREE HE WILL KICK YOUR ASS.
ROBERT DOBBIE!
THE SKELETONS IN HER CLOSET KEEP
HER HIGH IN CALCIUM, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
AND DAVID WILL BE A MAN HAS AN
NIGHTMARE ABOUT HIM, N.W.A. WILL
CHAMPION TYRUS!
MORGAN, YOU LOOK FANTASTIC!
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S LIKE A DISCO EASTER.
>> TOTALLY THE VIBE I WAS GOING
FOR.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE TRAVOLTA
AND AN EASTER BUNNY AND THEN
THREW UP.
ANYWAY.
I DIGRESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT KILLS ME ABOUT
THESE POLITICIANS THEY EXPECT US
TO ADOPT THEIR BELIEF SYSTEM
EVEN WHEN WE REJECT THEIRS.
WHY CAN'T WE CALL THE POLICE IF
YOU CAN CALL THE POLICE?
>> IT MAKES NO SENSE TO MOST
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY.
MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT THIS
WHOLE SEGMENT IS CONGRESSWOMAN
CORI BUSH SAID ON THE INTERVIEW
ESSENTIALLY LET'S NOT GET CAUGHT
UP IN WORDS.
THAT'S KIND OF THE WHOLE POINT
OF BEING IN CONGRESS, THE WHOLE
POINT IS TO WRITE LEGISLATION
AND TO GET CAUGHT UP IN THE
WORDS.
PART OF IT IS FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S
SO RIDICULOUS BUT WHEN YOU START
TO THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AS YOU SAID WHO ARE
INFECTED BY CRIME IN MAJOR
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY,
PEOPLE ARE MAKING DECISIONS AND
MOVING BASED ON THE STATISTICS
THAT HAVE REAL-WORLD IMPACTS.
>> Greg: WHERE ARE THEY GOING
TO MOVE?
NEW YORK IS THE PLACE TO BE.
YOU GOT THEATER, WHO CARES IF
YOU GET VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED.
YOU GOT TO SEE PIPPIN!
THAT'S MY ONLY MUSICAL
REFERENCE, PIPPIN.
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER SEEN A
MUSICAL IN MY LIFE EXCEPT IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND I HATED EVERY
MINUTE OF IT.
CONGRATS ON THE MOVIE, MY SON
HUNTER IS DOING GREAT.
YOU DIRECTED IT, WE'LL TALK
ABOUT IT LATER.
I BROUGHT THIS UP A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO ON THIS SHOW IT FEELS
LIKE LIFE IN NEW YORK AND A LOT
OF CITIES ARE BEGINNING TO MIMIC
MOVIES THAT WERE DYSTOPIAN CRIME
DRAMAS OR THINGS LIKE BATMAN
WHERE THE VILLAINS ARE CRAZY.
HOW DO YOU MAKE ANYTHING WORSE
THAN WHAT REALITY IS THAN THE
PERSON WHO STARRED IN MANIAC COP
TWO.
>> AND A THREE.
>> Greg: IS HE STILL A MANIAC?
>> HE'S A MANIAC BUT LESS THAN
ONE.
>> Greg: DOES HE BECOME A GOOD
GUY?
>> KIND OF, HE GETS MARRIED
PERIODS LIKE THE BRIDE OF
FRANKENSTEIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON?
>> I THINK WE ARE IN A DIFFICULT
TIME, AND THE KID OF THE 50s,
I WAS BORN IN QUEENS WHERE SHE
HAS HER PRECINCT.
I LEFT NEW YORK IN THE LATE
70s BECAUSE I WAS COMING OUT
OF A MACROBIOTIC RESTAURANT ON
THIRD AVENUE AND I MADE A LEFT
AND I HEARD A GUNSHOT AND THE
GUY COMING OUT AFTER ME WAS
LYING ON THE FLOOR.
THAT MADE ME SAY I'M GOING TO GO
TO LOS ANGELES.
45 YEARS IN L.A., I JUST MOVED
TO TAMPA BAY, FLORIDA.
I GOT THE HURRICANE.
THE ONE THING ABOUT THIS FOR ME,
WHEN I GREW UP THERE WAS A CODE
OF HONOR IN THE CITIES.
THE MAFIA, GOOD, BAD, OR
INDIFFERENT WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT DRUGS.
IF THE MAFIA WAS STILL AROUND
THERE WOULD BE NO FENTANYL,
THERE WOULD BE LESS CRIME IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
>> Greg: EXCEPT THEIR CRIME.
>> ACCEPT THEIR CRIME BUT THEY
KEPT IT TO THEMSELVES.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK YOU
WOULD HAVE ANY MOB VIOLENCE IN A
MACROBIOTIC RESTAURANT.
THAT'S GOOD TO STICK WITH ME I
DON'T CARE WHAT YOU SAY.
THAT IS THE CRIME.
FORGET EVERYTHING, WE ARE -- WHO
GOES TO A MACROBIOTIC
RESTAURANT?
YOU DESERVE TO BE SHOT.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT IS.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS WHAT TO
DO INSTEAD OF CALL THE COPS
GUIDE WAS THE PART THAT SAID TRY
TO USE EYE AND WE STATEMENTS,
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
I FEEL SAD WHEN I AM GETTING
STABBED.
WE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE WHEN WE
HAVE A GUN IN OUR FACE.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD BE
CALLING THE COPS FOR EVERY
LITTLE THING BUT THE SECTION
ABOUT WHAT TO DO IF YOU ARE ON
AN ESCALATING SITUATION CONFLICT
DOESN'T EVEN MENTION THE
POSSIBILITY THAT YOU MIGHT EVER
NEED TO CALL THE COPS AT ALL.
THERE WAS THIS PART THAT SAID
REPEAT THE SAME STATEMENT UNTIL
THE PERSON CAUSING HARMS
CORRECTS THEIR BEHAVIOR OR
STOPS.
FOR EXAMPLE, HAVE A GOOD DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S WHAT IT SAID!
YOU DON'T NEED A GUN, YOU HAVE
ALL OF THOSE HAVE A GOOD DAY IN
YOUR ARSENAL.
IT'S CRAZY AND WHAT IS CRAZIER
IS -- IT ASSUMES IF YOU DO THIS
YOUR THEY'RE GOING TO BE LIKE
NEVER MIND AND GO AWAY, THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE THE CASE I WOULD
SAY MOST OF THE TIME.
>> Greg: IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
THEY WOULD HAVE A GOOD DAY.
>> IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO YELL HAVE
A GOOD DAY WHILE THEY ARE
STABBING YOU.
>> IT USED TO BE MAKE MY DAY.
I THINK WE NEED MORE OF THAT.
>> IN ANOTHER LIFE WHEN I WAS A
SCHOOLTEACHER AND I WORKED WITH
DEVELOPMENTALLY CHALLENGED
CHILDREN, THIS IS THE SAME
HANDBOOK.
THEY WOULD SAY USE STATEMENTS TO
GET THE CHILD'S ATTENTION,
REPEAT YOURSELF IN CASE THEY
DON'T LISTEN AND EVEN THEN, THEY
DIDN'T LISTEN.
SO YOU THINK YOUR HEAD START IN
BLUE THEY THROUGHOUT -- THE ONLY
THING YOU DIDN'T SEE WAS HAVING
TO USE BASKET RESTRAINTS -- WHEN
ALL ELSE FAILS WHEN THEY DON'T
RESTRAIN THE CHILD UNTIL HELP
COMES ALONG -- THAT'S THE ONLY
PART THEY LEFT OFF.
YOU MENTIONED IT -- THE ENTIRE
REVOLUTION IS ABOUT WORDS.
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR LIVELIHOODS
BECAUSE THEY USE THE WRONG WORD,
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT -- ANYTHING
YOU SAY HURT ME, WORDS MATTER.
BUT WHEN YOU COME AT THEM
>> President Biden: IS NOT
ABOUT WORDS.
>> I THOUGHT WORDS WERE THE
VIOLENCE.
>> MY PRONOUN IS WHAT THE
[BLEEP] >> Greg: THAT'S A
T-SHIRT!
I WOULD DEFINITELY WEAR THAT TO
DISCO EASTER.
AND HE WOULD BE MY DATE -- DISCO
EASTER.
>> I'M JEWISH.
>> ARE YOU JEWISH, DOES THAT
MATTER?
>> THE WHOLE THING IS ABOUT
KILLING.
>> ONE OF BILL O'REILLY'S GREAT
BOOKS.